hello guys my name is Jana and welcome
to episode 124 of game programming so
last time we finished up the UI and the
buttons and one on we actually had our
own image inside the button this little
kind of thing here and we did some image
brightness stuff and whatever and we've
got a pretty good set up going on for
the UI right now I'm just what I'm I can
pretty much call it complete except for
the fact that when we clicked over on
this panel it actually continued to
shoot of course we put in something to
stop that over here and that was this if
mouse get X is greater than 616 and
whatever we put on we put in this whole
system to stop that and whatnot but I
asked you guys if you wanted me to do it
properly you know basically by
converting this into like I'll kind of
layered game with with layers and with
events and you guys said yes I made a
standalone video for that it's called
like event system and dispatcher or
something I don't know it was called but
it's there'll be a link to that video in
the description so I highly recommend
you watch that video before you go ahead
and watch this one because that one is
going to explain how the entire bed
system works okay and that video of
course will be kind of the preface to
this video because in this video all
we're going to do is we're gonna kind of
copy the code from that 'allah video
from that example that I made and
integrate it into into rain so that's
kind of the idea okay speaking of which
this game is called rain so we should
have we probably have some kind of rain
effects going on I think I think I think
that would be good so if you guys want
to see that just leave a comment below
and um you know and we'll get we'll get
around to that but anyway so I want to
said copy I literally meant copy because
I've got basically both folders open
right now and I'm going to be copying
them so layers we want write that as it
like our base can't lay a configuration
and we want advanced but I really need
core this is from the other video by the
way and this is also in github but yeah
we don't really need the core but we do
want events and layers so I'm going to
copy that and we can actually just put
it right on into here okay layers I'm
actually going to move it to graphics
though that's the only change I'm going
to me if we come back here right click
hit refresh or we can hit f5 as well
with that selected
we will see our new code in the in the
project so we've got like a bunch of
errors here which is fine so we have to
basically reconfigure all this stuff
then listen I'm gonna have to report
that event which probably just go
through every file right now fix up the
package declarations if you hover your
mouse over the error and select change
package declaration to well that one
then it should work out lovely all right
and yes this will take a bit of time
unfortunately mouse press match so this
is just for Mouse events so far we'll
hook in some key events and whatnot in
the future so we're kind of making some
engine changes here that probably going
to be for the better because as I said
as I told you guys I want to kind of
take this game to the next level and I
want to make it a game that we can
pretty much release like as in we want
to meet that quality so that's why
that's why I'm doing all this stuff so
let's see what do we need to import
right now we want to import what are we
trying to import them would be good if
you told me because I don't know so
event type is probably what we want
that's one side of me shouldn't need
that yeah there we go
not sure why cliffs was asking us for
that I'm just hitting ctrl shift oh by
the way to bring up that organizing
pause dialogue all right set it that's
it
okay cool know what no more errors so
let's integrate everything to use layers
so the way this is going to work is
we're going to basically go to our level
glass right now and we're going to make
it so that level extends layer okay
because level is going to be a layer we
don't really have a layer stack right
now we will set that up in a minute
so that'll be our game class it looks
like so anyway you can see nothing's
basically changed if I actually go into
layer though I want to see what kind of
stuff we haven't land that we should be
overriding so there's on update there's
on render so I'll change these to render
and up
to match our kind of convention on
events I guess I will just leave it on
event because if I change it to event
that just looks kind of weird
both 48 event yeah we'll leave it as on
event okay cool
so if we go to render we want screen
screen of course to be eating here
instead of graphics G and update I think
is pretty much the same cool so now we
should be getting one way to check is if
you look at this you should be seeing
this is the player you should be seeing
was update you should be seeing like a
green arrow that just basically is a
clip telling you that you're writing
something and you should see the same
for render if you don't like for example
we don't that's problem so that's
because our render method takes in like
a scroll and Y scroll which is a bit
weird so let's not make it do that let's
quickly just make a public void set
scroll because I'm pretty sure we've got
something like that anyway don't we
explore wise girl do we not have that
probably not well we do now so we'll
make a private int X scroll Y scroll
this game really needs some refactoring
to be honest obviously it's been three
years since I started it so I do things
a lot differently now but I'm a much
better program and now than I was back
then
but anyway regardless of that we will
continue going on with this stuff okay
so and I'll kind of I guess slowly over
time will be refactoring and stuff I'm
not going to spend like ten episodes now
rewriting everything or anything like
that but we're going to kind of just
slowly gradually you know and little
things like this just kind of changing
it up a bit so basically all this all
that's changed is we just have to call
one extra method here
there we go okay and once to
double-check the game is still working
as expected and it is great so now let's
close all these event classes now we
need to hook up our event system into
our kind of window class which is really
just this class because you can see they
were doing everything like adding
carelessness any mouse listeners and all
that stuff yeah into here
you know the frames for example we're
doing a last stuff in this class so
that's why we have to kind of make it
work with that so what we're going to do
is let's see so we've got the layer so
we'll have to make a layer stack so
private list layer four layer stack
equals new ArrayList layer on pour to
that make sure you import the one that's
in util not AWT when I was looking for
the GUI version of list we're looking
for the actual data structure so layer
stack is our last acts great so every
time we hadn't we add a layer let's make
a let's just quickly make a public void
add layer layer layer layer stack top
add layout okay so what we'll do is
we've got a key list already that's how
keyboard and we've gone our mouse so if
we actually if you guys were to go back
to the other video and see how it worked
all we did is we kind of we essentially
made an event and when we made an event
we we kind of we called a non-event
method which basically looped through
everything and handled it okay so what
I'm going to do is this I'm going to
make it so that game actually implements
an event the event listener which might
be a bit weird because layers by the way
do that as you can see the reason I'm
doing this is because I'm going to
actually make it so that Mouse requires
when we make the mouse public so
basically we don't really need any of
this to be static anymore but when we
make this we're going to make it so that
this takes in an eventlistener because
we want to hook up this mouse into an
event listener because the event
listener is where it's going to send all
the events right hopefully this is
making sense so public event listener
event listener
alright I'll hook this up and then when
we have all this will have to us we'll
have to basically sort them out there so
we'll add this and we'll add the
listeners all right so let's quickly set
it up for the mouse right we're kind of
going to so what we we aren't changing
this system I'll still keep the static
stuff around just in case we need them
but I'll probably start changing the
knobs to be honest so when we move we
wants to have create a new mouse move
event mouse moved event
yo get X eat or get Y and drag is false
and then what we want to do is web the
event listeners here we're going to call
event listener dot on event with the
event here alright pretty simple stuff
so this obviously needs to implement on
event I'll pop it right over here public
void on event event event okay because
what this is going to do is just
basically send it down the layer stack
now events go down to layer stack in
reverse order so what we need to do is
we need to say for int I equals
basically the last thing in the layer
stack which will be layer stack dot get
o rather last all right let's talk about
size minus one that's the last element I
is greater than or equal to zero so it
goes all the way to the beginning of a
player stack and then I - - okay so
that's basically going to iterate
through the layer stack but in Reverse
so from the middle from the end to the
beginning rather than from the beginning
to the end so all we have to do here is
say layer stack dot yet I dot on event
because obviously oops
because obviously every layer is an
event listener
okay cool anyway so now we should be
getting events so if we go into like
say the level you you would see that the
level so the level extends layout so we
need to basically over I that on event
method I think we just did
no we didn't so we've got squares
updates will update how about that
public void on events okay now this is
where the events get received so
basically what we usually want to do is
just basically raise that event for
every single entity again in the entity
can choose what to do with the event
okay we don't really want to block
events or anything like that in this
case but that's kind of how it works
right now so anyway there is two
different things that I should mention
though in the event thing there's an
event listener there's an event handler
okay an event handler is something that
actually handles the event this returns
a boolean and this hat this could stop
the dispatcher from taking place but
remember we're not really talking about
just when I'm really talking about the
event dispatcher right now at all it's
not actually a thing an event dispatcher
is I'm going to use to just dispatch
events when you're actually inside a non
event thing okay that's that's all you
do that's kind of the endpoint solution
right we're kind of still in the middle
of things because level really probably
won't do too much with on event but we
do want to send it to things like the
player okay so that being said the yell
like the player is actually a really
good example of where we want to send
events to like we probably don't want to
send events to entities for example I
wouldn't really make too much sense we
could do that though right we could do
that in situations where we want the
enemies to react to player's events
which is a bit weird like you might not
do that it doesn't really make too much
sense to do that because events right
now at least are just kind of user input
style things in the future there could
be anything they like literally anything
but right now they're just user input
things so it does make too much sense to
do that but anyway we can get I don't
know why this is call to get player
times list
we call get players but anyway well you
have the client player which is the
current player and we can send an event
there because really again if we are
talking about a multiple
scenario which is why we've got like the
get client player here a really the
client player is the only one who raises
events because right now it has her
input events and they get raised or they
should get sent to the client player so
what we'll do is we'll say get a client
player dot on event event so the player
is going to implement the event listener
interface which is going to add we're
going to add that on event gonna pop it
right before update and there we go so
now we can set up an event dispatcher
and we can do things like shoot and
whatnot when things happen which is
great so if we go back to Mouse real
quick I'm just going to finish making
events for everything so drags it's
going to do the same but with true mouse
pressed is going to be mouse press event
okay and I believe that just takes in
indeed boolean so I'll so it doesn't
take anything bullying takes in into end
so the button I think is first let's see
the button is first and then the
coordinates so we'll take in the button
which is a dog get button and then we'll
take in things this is actually
additional information as well I mean we
didn't have it before you would have to
call two methods you would have to call
the get mouse button and they get X and
get Y but now we kind of have it all in
that event which is nice and released of
course we'll do the exact same thing so
it's going to be a mouse release event
okay I think that's it isn't it that
sounds like it's it you know we would
have other events such as focus lost
focus mostly I was it effects lost focus
focused I don't know anyway
focus lost focus gained whatever you
could we would have events for that if
we have focus listeners as well that's
not common thing to do in Java and in
games in general but um it's yes we
could raise events for that as well okay
cool anyway so
now that we've done that we should be
able to capture events already in in the
player class already okay the final
thing we haven't done is set up a proper
rendering system for events so right now
we have this level dot sets for all
staff and we kind of dual this a lil dat
render shouldn't this shouldn't be
called anymore okay what should happen
this is where we render layers
okay so we'll basically say for each
layer layer stack don't size I will
basically just call last act okay I
don't render screen okay and then when
we make the level at the top here
well actually or we where we do the we
set it to level spawn whatever we just
will just basically say add layer level
okay and we don't need to update anymore
either so I'm gonna copy this I'm going
to say update layers here and we're
basically is going to change this to
update okay done so if we were on the
game now we should hopefully be at the
same situation as we are now and we are
which is good so now we need to change
the only thing we need to change is we
need to see first of all if players get
events correctly so if we go to player
the best way to see any of this really
is just to print out the current event
so if we just print out the event will
get the name of the event you can say we
get ton of mouse moved events we get
mouse press mouse release events when we
actually press in a release like over
here for example press release try it we
get all that stuff which is good so it's
working that's basically the main thing
this is where event dispatcher comes in
so we're going to say ventus Pedro
dispatcher equals new event dispatcher
event okay and now what we're going to
do is we're going to basically write a
bunch of events for all these things so
public void on Mouse move do we really
need to handle that too much do we
really we just want mouse press so mouse
press event e we want Mouse release I
think that's probably about it to be
honest okay one plot those are there
should be bullies by the way okay and
we'll just return false right now okay
cool so so what we want to do right now
is just call dispatch a dog dispatch the
type will be event dot type dot mouse
press try the handle for that is going
to be a lambda and it's going to be just
a mouse press event we're going to cost
it to that and what we were calling I
was calling the on mousepressed method
so all mousepressed a is that the syntax
I don't even know twenty seven films
first of all that's what I meant
I think or is that what I meant I
haven't written lambdas in Java in a
while that's what I meant
I think this is great oh okay that was
right I just have to change my pressure
compliance to Jerry yet well guys looks
like we're finally making switch into
Java 8
okay cow knob Sarita Claire as it just
as that isn't it
is it okay I'm going to quickly see what
I did before because I do lambdas in
Java too often where would I have done
that I would have done at an example
later and the other project Oh close so
event event it were a name - cool that's
close
all right sorry we've got the
mousepressed event and now we'll do the
my mouse released
event released event okay and now we
should have everything working pretty
well what's wrong with you I wonder yeah
you totally should be though did I screw
up my mouse released yeah some thing
okay cool there we go so lambdas are
just basically a shorter way of writing
like in an inner classic and basically
so the alternative would have been to do
something like new event handler and
then call like you know return on Mouse
pressed event that's exactly the same
code okay and then you'd have to cast it
yeah that's the same thing except our
system is way cooler all right cool
there we go
so now that we've done that we should be
able to basically handle all that stuff
pretty easily so we've got as getbutton
fire right stuff so update shooting it's
kind of a something that we don't really
need to do anymore okay because now we
can handle this stuff in the event
system so if I literally cut this update
shooting and put it onto on mousepressed
so you know we'll just return false or
whatever if that's the case we don't
need to do the get button anymore this
this comes from the event now so it's
going to be eat or get button equals or
do like Mouse event dot part in one I
guess I was hoping for something like a
left button but what I guess we get what
we get that's the left mouse button
right I hope so button one whatever that
means were they being equal to one I
guess it's the same thing as what we had
before
what oh excuse me okay so fire it listen
yeah we got that stuff going on now if
this happens we might want to return
true okay that means that we've totally
handle the event whoops we've totally
handle the event and we don't want
anyone else to handle it anymore okay
otherwise we'll just return false okay
cool and if this happens we can yeah we
can return false pretty much straight
away we probably don't even have to do
that anymore to be honest okay cool so
I'll get rid of see mouse released do
really doesn't even need to be a thing
anymore it probably doesn't at least so
we'll get rid of update shooting we can
get rid of it here and if we launch this
we should still be able to shoot and you
can see what you can I don't think we
can hold the mouse down anymore looks
like we're gonna in the we can't kind of
leave it press you have to keep clicking
on it which is a bit annoying so what do
we have
let's see so first of all it looks like
that event isn't going to get raised as
long as the mouse is press only when it
gets pressed okay so the way that you
can do something like that is pretty
simple we basically we basically have
something in player that's like private
boolean shooting is false if let's see
where are we so on mousepressed if this
is true we simply start shooting equal
to true over here if the button is the
correct button and we release it well
set shooting equal to false will return
true and that should be about it so now
this code which is really the the juicy
part we can basically just put into the
update loop so we can we'll still we can
still have something like update
shooting or something private void
update shooting and of course we can say
that if not shooting or turn ok there we
go so if we run that we should be able
to shoot and as you can see we totally
can and we're shooting a lot very
quickly and I assume that's because of
that fire rate so one thing we should
say is that yeah we definitely don't
wanna be shooting so this and fire rate
stuff don't really care about that we
could say something like if fire rates
of shooting or fire rate is greater than
zero then term I really need to be doing
okay and then we've got out back we're
back to our kind of old self with the
event system okay cool so anyway that's
pretty much gonna wrap up this episode I
don't want to make this one too long but
that is kind of the beginning of the
refactoring for a while those impulse
crazy that's basically the beginning of
the refactoring for the event system
next time we're going to refactor the UI
stuff so what I mean by that is we've
got the UI buttons and your wife panels
really which we're going to have event
listeners and of course we're going to
be able to block events based on where
like you know basically whether or not
the event happened on that certain
layout and whatnot and we're going to
transform UI panels on the entire UI
manager system into basically a UI layer
so we'll rent out that concept and
overall it should be definitely pretty
cool now if you guys do enjoy this
series then the best way to support it
would be on patreon so I do have a
patreon accounts patreon.com for said
sure no here it is right over here you
can essentially pledge a given amount
and the bet the best thing you can do
you can really do is pledge $5 or more
because if you do you'll get access to
all the source code for the escape
programming series on github via a
private repository so you'll have all
the code for this game programming
series as well as as well as all the
differences between commits because
every episode I'm making you commit and
you'll be able to compare the difference
of what I've changed episode per episode
which is pretty cool I think so anyway
if you're interested in that you can of
course click link in the description and
support me on patreon that of that also
ensures that I make more videos as well
which is always a good thing but other
than that if you did enjoy hit a like
button and I will see you guys next time
as we continue making rain good bye
you